you know I wanted to share with you a
principle that's worked well for me for
nearly 20 years when I tell you it's
proven it's a hundred percent proven
here's what it is by the way this only
applies if you work hard and you
continuously improve it only applies if
you do that if you don't do that what
I'm about to tell you doesn't work let
me simplify it for you
20 years straight every single time I've
kept my head down and got to work every
single time I've been curious and stayed
in the shoshone mentality The Beginner's
mentality to improve every single time I
don't know why it is every time I get
lucky a new contact changes the life of
my year business a new client completely
changes the game a new business partner
new sales person a new executive a new
something changes everything about the
business for 20 straight years this has
been the case so if you're working hard
and nothing is going your way but you
know you're improving a working heart
just know something great is around the
corner for you